we have a draft to do and it's in the
spirit of jamal adams wanting out of the
jets players who would get more
recognition from a change of scenery the
trivia question goes to you big cat and
it's very simple what position did jamal
adams father george play
in the nfl
hmm
[Music]
wide receiver
close running back slash fullbacks
that counts that counts
okay it counts all right no no go ahead
you go first you go first i i i am going
first once i get my notes here i i hear
i'm i'm here's where i'm starting
i i i one of the guys that always finds
a way to be one of my picks whatever the
draft may be i am going to go with
russell wilson yes i am russell wilson
relegated to the pacific northwest where
he does not have the kind of national
following that he should have and one of
these days one of these days russell
wilson is going to be on a team with a
higher profile one of these days russell
wilson is going to be regarded as much
more of a star than he currently is once
he's off the seahawks and i know the
seahawks have a very loyal and ardent
fan base
but it's not that cross over national
appeal that he otherwise could have if
he was playing save for a new york team
so russell wilson would benefit from a
change of scenery and i say that because
i believe deep down russell wilson
believes he would benefit from a change
of scenery
wow
mike okay so you're talking about
outside of the football field i was
thinking more inside the football field
um i'll start with
uh those jerseys by the way i love those
i know some people just hate them the
the color i hate them
i know because you you don't have an eye
for beautiful things okay um
listen i'm gonna go with number one what
was that what was that what were you
gonna say
nothing i'm not saying anything go ahead
go ahead i don't know why anybody likes
those look when you pick a highlight
green highlighter or you just pick the
yellow one it's that hideous lime green
highlighter that nobody ever buys and
they had to discontinue it that's what
that jersey is okay i'm done i like it i
think it looks cool i'm gonna go with my
first pick aj green aj green is uh a
little bit later in his career i think
joe burrow's gonna be a fantastic
quarterback in the nfl but of course
when you have a rookie quarterback it
takes some time aj green has uh
expressed that he would like to be
somewhere else i think he we kind of
forget about who aj green is and how
fantastic he is and i think that if he
went to a big
market place with uh you know where he
was the featured wide receiver we'd be
talking about aj green a little bit of a
different light
i don't disagree with that but for the
fact they didn't play at all last year
not because of
uh the bengals but because he was
injured we've kind of forgotten about aj
green and and i agree with you it's time
for him to play somewhere else and maybe
after this year that he will and i think
that anybody who is mired on the bengals
as they've been
is going to be forgotten and overlooked
but at the same time things may change
and that may be the great irony here aj
green may be winding up his time in
cincinnati just as they're on the cusp
of unlocking a team that is a consistent
contender of joe burrow become your
friend joe burrow becomes the guy that
uh
my friend too i'm gonna count myself as
a friend i've talked to him we got along
uh anyway uh
i'll go with aj i agree with you on aj
green my next one is matthew stafford
detroit lions quarterback i feel like he
and and look chris sims put him in the
top ten number nine for stafford a
couple of years ago sims had matthew
stafford at number three top three
quarterback in the nfl and it just look
uh i it's a chicken in the egg type of a
thing people think the lions have
continued to be bad because stafford
isn't good enough to make them better
others would say they continue to be bad
just because they're bad and they've
been bad for 60 years and that's just
kind of the way it is that team has such
deep-seated dysfunction that even a
great quarterback can't pull them out of
it i'd like to see mainly as a
laboratory experiment what matthew
stafford would do if you put him with a
better organization with a better cast
of characters with a front office that
that was not trying to shed decades of
dysfunction would stafford become that
star that he's always deserved to be
that's a good pick mike that's a good
pick i will stay in the nfc north for my
next pick
and i do this uh out of the kindness of
my heart
i think aaron rodgers has been
mistreated i think the packers have not
supported him i think the packers have
given him mixed messages i think
drafting jordan love was an affront to
aaron rodgers and all he's done for
green bay i think not drafting wide
receiver weapons was a slap in his face
and i'll just sit here and say this
aaron rodgers you should probably demand
a trade because it's not fair what the
packers are doing to you and you would
benefit from a change of scenery that's
just me being a nice guy
i know i'm sure yes absolutely that's
you know it reminds me of what vikings
coach mike zimmer said to the media
after the first round of the draft this
year when they asked him for his
reaction on the packers trading up to
take quarterback jordan love
zimmer said well that they should trade
aaron rodgers now uh yeah the other
teams i think i agree with mike zimmer
yeah they would love they would love to
see aaron rodgers get traded and the
thing is after this year
there's a chance he will be
after this year
and at the latest after next year once
you go all in with jordan love
and when you trade up to get jordan love
you're telling the world at some point
he's going to be your quarterback the
question is how many more years will
aaron rodgers be the guy so not that
it's going to happen now it could happen
after this season i think after 2021 it
becomes far more likely that roger's
going to move out because look he's
going to get into that jamal adams
mindset if he isn't already there where
he wants to go you know we we typically
look at a player getting traded from the
perspective of what the team wants we
are in an era it's not quite the nba yet
but we are in an era where football
players are realizing they do have more
power especially a quarterback you know
it's one thing to say to a running back
a receiver a lineman hey you got a
contract you play for us or you play for
no one you try to do that to a
quarterback who wants out the
quarterback says fine i'm not showing up
early i'm not staying late i'm not
watching film at home i'm not doing
anything other than the bare minimum i'm
not going to hold my teammates
accountable i'm not going to be that
quasi member of management that you need
the starting quarterback to be i'm just
not going to do it and if you want me
here and i don't want to be here and i
do the bare minimum good luck winning
football games and i think that's that's
a an element of leverage that
the other players on a team don't have
big cat
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely so i
think we both agree aaron rodgers
demanded trade right now
today
today demand of trade package deal with
jamal adams uh
trade aaron rodgers to the jets straight
up for jamal adams although nfc north
teams would probably not want jamal
adams in the division either all right
i'm gonna go
with
and this one's gonna surprise you and
i'll explain myself i'm going with alvin
kamara
because
there are people in the saints
organization that believe that alvin
kamara is every bit as good as christian
mccaffrey if not better the problem is
the saints don't use running backs the
way that the panthers are using
christian mccaffrey if alvin kamara
truly wants to become and i don't know
what his agenda is maybe he's happy
being a part-time player maybe he's
happy being a smaller piece in a larger
machine maybe he understands it extends
his career and he's more likely to play
into his 30s than christian mccaffrey
who has all these touches and all the
contact and all the potential injuries
but alvin mc alvin kamara would become
a superstar in the national football
league if he was on a team that gave him
the ball the number of times that
christian mccaffrey gets the ball it's
that simple so whether he wants it or
not
his profile would definitely be elevated
if he was playing for a team that made
him the workhorse the way the panthers
have made mccaffrey the workhorse in
carolina okay you know what i'm gonna do
mike my last pick i'm gonna go mono e
mono with you on this one and my last
pick is going to be
christian mccaffrey i think christian
mccaffrey would benefit from a change of
scenery and here's why
the panthers are rebuilding the panthers
are starting over teddy bridgewater nice
quarterback probably a stop gap they've
kind of got it they you know they cam
newton's gone luke lee's gone the the
face of the franchise is kind of gone
right now it's gonna be christian
mccaffrey but it's still the carolina
panthers that's not a marquee franchise
here's what's also gonna happen mike i
expect the panthers to probably not win
a lot of games the next few years
they're probably not going to be in the
playoffs what happens to hall of fame
type players that don't get that playoff
you know experience so play those huge
games there's a ceiling
to
where they can go in terms of the lore
of the nfl chris mccaffrey is a
fantastic player if christopher caffrey
was a piece on a playoff team we would
be talking about him in a lot different
light than we're talking about him right
now where there will be a lot of empty
yards so to speak where chris mccaffery
puts up great stats on a team that
doesn't win and that's always a
different conversation than a guy who
puts up great stats on a team that does
win and is in the conversation for a
super bowl so my pick is christian
mccaffrey
so basically what we have agreed here is
that
the saints and the panthers should trade
alvin kamara for christian mccaffrey
yes exactly that would elevate both of
them
yes uh okay that you know what there's
it's crazy enough that it actually at
some level has some appeal the problem
is in new orleans christian mccaffrey
would not be christian mccaffrey he'd be
alvin camaro because they would not give
him the ball as much as he gets it in
carolina but his career would be
extended and he'd be part of a team that
is competing for playoff positioning and
championship so uh there's merit to both
points all right let's let's do one more
round very quickly very quickly all
right i'll do the first one
i'll go for it sure go ahead
all right take take some hell we'll stay
with the saints taysom hill is a
franchise quarterback taysom hill is a
franchise quarterback who is just
waiting to blossom someone needs to let
take some hell out of this box let him
be a franchise quarterback let him be
the face of a franchise uh let him throw
the ball 60 times a game
i that's that's just a fact so taysom
hill would you would benefit from a
change of scenery
this was a nice reasonable draft until i
decided to let your nature you do a good
job and you've been doing an excellent
job today it must be the new apartment
you have not been an ass at all today it
took 74 minutes the over under was 72
and a half minutes you just barely got
the over of when you were gonna be an
ass today uh and you make me regret that
i went to a fourth round if we're doing
a real fourth round let me get how about
this how about this how about aaron
donald
on a new team not that the rams would
ever do it not that they'd ever do it
but you know i feel like that team's
disintegrating i feel like that team is
quickly falling apart i feel like aaron
donald needs to be on a team where that
dominance is going to be the you know
look at what khalil mack did for the
bears for one for one year it was only
for one year but but think about what
aaron donald could be if you plugged him
into a team that that had all the other
pieces and it felt like the arrow was
pointing up i just feel like the arrow
is flat or pointing down for the rams
right now especially in that division
uh i mean l.a hard knocks new stadium
you're wrong give me taste some help
nobody cares nobody cares about the rams
in la isn't that weird for what
nationals
[Music]
isn't that the whole play with the la
teams i don't know that anybody cares
about the la teams and then they they
come out with these new uniforms that
are just hideous and and and you know i
know the new stadium is going to be
great if you watch them on tv who cares
i think look the chargers talking this
week about sonic colin kaepernick and
and i know that anthony lynn isn't
bringing him in anytime soon but he's
made it clear he's on the list in the
event that they need someone
uh if the chargers would make that move
they would leave the rams in the dust
both locally and nationally but i think
aaron donald maybe
not again he's the one long-term
contract decision they've made that's
worked out really well in the past five
years they're not ever going to let him
go he's one of those untouchable players
but he would benefit i think from being
on a team bring him back to pittsburgh
wouldn't he be something as a member of
the steelers wouldn't that just be the
ultimate move to get him back in
pittsburgh where he played college
football and it's almost like the jerome
bettis move remember he was a ram before
he became a stealer so it's not going to
happen but it's fun to talk about
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports